[Applaudissements]
bonjour namasté donc je suis au pays je
viens de new delhi et j'ai beaucoup de
chance dans la vie
mes parents ils ont eu trois filles donc
moi la dernière et je suis encore
vivante
donc ça c'est bien hollande de garder
des filles bien sûr et j'ai eu cette
possibilité d'apprendre de culture
puisque j'habite à nyon j'habite à new
delhi en même temps presque
j'habite à deauville magnifique deux
pays de culture et plusieurs langues
donc aujourd'hui modestement je parle
avec vous en français c'est ma première
présentation en français
donc aujourd'hui je voulais vous habitez
un petit voyage un peu loin à new delhi
ma ville donc bien sûr new delhi c'est
la capitale de l'inde ces majestueux
nous avons des grandes rues il y a des
beaux monuments historiques
mais comme je peux être je vous pose une
question que pensez-vous de l'inde
et je pense que la premier même
maintenant à ce moment là vous allez
dire alors c'est un pays peuplé crade
salle on vit dans un montagne de des
ordures
on est vraiment dans un pays d'aix taux
plein on comprend rien comment les gens
vivent dans ce pays
mais aujourd'hui en fait je vous
invitais à voyager avec moi et je
présente aussi ma petite ville new delhi
avec 20 millions d'habitants
20 millions c'est beaucoup c'est presque
un quart de la population française de
mobiles et cette ville est magnifique
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps et j'ai
étudié là bas j'ai passé mon enfance et
je pensais que avec la globalisation ça
va changer
bien sûr landes va changer un peu bien
sûr et on parle de 2084 mais aujourd'hui
je commence mon voyage
bien sûr avec les enfants c'est pas en
voyage avec un joli hôtel ou tard mais
elle des monuments historiques parce que
les arbres font partie de notre ville je
suis grandi avec ses tables s'est
adressé dans la rue on les adore ces
deux lieux de rencontre c'est des
monuments historiques pour nous c'est
désabre joël petit grand centenaire et
on a bien sûr un bon autour de ces
arbres donc nous guérit c'est pas des
grosses montagnes et des ordures les
plastiques emballages et en plus parfois
je rigole avec mes étudiants ici je dis
bien sûr non seulement entre et nos
propres déchets on traite les déchets
des autres pays
en plus on a une mauvaise réputation
dans le monde
vous voyez la chine l'inde ces deux
grands pays pollués mais en fait vous
plantez pas contourner 1,3 milliard et
personnellement je trouve je vous invite
à voyager un petit peu ma vie
quotidienne à nantes
donc les arbres non seulement ils
habitent beaucoup d'oiseaux bien sûr
aujourd'hui on peut pas couper les
arbres
il y à même les adresses postales bien
sûr vraie adresse postale autour des
arbres le bureau se trouve derrière sa
table de long contre l'île de ré père
est aujourd'hui bien sûr même les arbres
poussent partout à new delhi mais ils
ont petit danger avec nos petits charme
et aligot des bus
on ne peut pas couper les branches donc
bien sûr on commence notre voyage la
journée avec les humbles les arbres sont
bien sûr des corps et tous les jours on
met des fleurs il y a des bons autour et
la vie quotidienne
bien sûr de contemplation de réflexion
parfois je me produis promène on était
effet 40 43 degrés mais sous les arbres
bien sûr il fait 38
c'est moins chaud mais c'est bien
je trouve ça bien c est parfois je
trouve que parfois les arbres sont
tellement puissants ils poussent nos
barrières
il détruit les trottoirs mais c'est pas
problème on a un travaux publics bien
sûr on va attendre quelques décennies
pour réparer les dortoirs mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave donc on commence
la vie sous les arbres parce que bien
sûr la vie commence le voyage avec notre
hôtel est sous les arbres nous avons
street food on a des mots street food
vous pouvez trouver variété des boissons
jus de fruits des fruits partout partout
puisque nous sommes presque le guitar ya
90 90 % des indiens sauvette italien
parce que nous avons plein de tradition
beaucoup de religions on mange pas ça on
mange pas ça le bac c'est sacré
le singe est mignon donc elle ne peut
pas manger la viande et il fait trop
chaud il fait trop chaud
donc on va aller vers les cannes à sucre
notre stricte [ __ ]
pas besoin de dépenser beaucoup vous
voyez les prix c'est des rubis des lupi
c'est à dire c'est moins d'un centime
d'euro
donc pourquoi dépenser pour coca cola au
bout des boissons qui nous coûte
beaucoup plus cher et plus il n'ya pas
d'emballage pas de conservateurs nous
sommes là tranquille entre les amis
après les cours avant le travail après
le travail pour avoir ces jus de fruits
donc on a plombé toujours street food
nous séduit tout le temps on peut pas
être indifférent
on peut être bien sûr avec la famille et
j'avais peur de vivre bien sûr en france
et détournés chaque faux nom pour
trouver des changements mais nous mes
photos que j'ai pris par hasard comme ça
dans la rue je trouve que même les
jeunes ils adorent ça
donc depuis des siècles on a suivi les
mêmes gestes des gestes très simples
authentiques et pour une grande sortie
avec les enfants les affres les enfants
adorent ça
donc les fruits vient de partout de
l'inde ces petites économies slow food
et en plus ces gens sont aussi des
auto-entrepreneurs moitié de notre
économie aussi ça appartient à ces gens
qui sont des étals sous la voûte les
bords de la route
vous pouvez boire du thé vous pouvez
boire tout alors et puis notre voyage
vers midi à me dis qu'est-ce qui se
passe vous vous allez je ne sais pas
dans une boulangerie pour acheter des
petits snacks et nous nous avons des
livres des langes barça va dire presque
les boîtes déjeuner qui vient des prix
chez vous jusqu'à à votre bureau en
université
c'est une grande organisation unique au
monde
ça fait cent vingt-cinq ans ces livres
qui appartient à une religion à une
association qui compose de cinq mille
hommes de la même past c'est très
complexe je peux pas vous expliquer dans
quelques minutes
il apporte notre langue supporte notre
boîte déjeuner tous les jours il n'y a
pas d'erreur
sans aucun système informatisé son être
branché avec les portables avec aucun
système informatisé et ça fait cent
vingt-cinq ans n'ont pas failli et
légaux dans mon quartier à lyon il dit
ah là là il y a eu des rites furent doha
mais non nous avons un système plan b
vous avez votre boîte déjeuner tout de
suite livré à votre lieu de travail ou
même à école parce qu'on n'a pas de
continue donc ses jambes apportent tous
parfois ces gens n'ont pas aussi eu
l'occasion d'aller à l'école ils sont
illettrés analphabètes mais ils ont
codage c'est unique au monde est
aujourd'hui bien sûr l'association de
ces d'imbaba là sans qu'on dit en hindi
sont très très connu ils ont même
inspiré tous les stats ap américain
il y a aussi la logistique humain qui
est performant et il y a même pas une
erreur il ya eu une erreur parmi 6000
watts déjeuner qui sont livrés à votre
bureau
donc bien sûr on a des livres bien sûr
ou berit mais à l'ancienne ils n'ont pas
besoin des taxis ou des camions tous a
tout fait sur le tête avec bien sûr un
système de logistique très
impressionnant
donc je commence aussi bien tout donner
dans les shopping c'est la journée
j'adore fait le shop in one and ça m'a
fait plaisir parfois j'écoute mes
français mes amis français il dit ah là
là on doit aller au supermarché sur
nouilles aux lancers horrible et on
entre on a ont toujours des petits
magasins
on a bien sûr beaucoup de temples du
temple aldo bouddhiste j'aime beaucoup
de religions mais on n'a pas encore les
temples de consommation on a résisté
on n'a pas ces grands temples et la
première fois que je suis venu en france
parce que j'adore la france bien sûr
en 92 avec un programme déclenché
j'étais dans une famille française très
gentil très sympathique il m'a montré
leur cave
j'étais horrifiée mais même j'étais
vraiment surprise avec des congénères
j'ai jamais vu dans ma vie timos
congélateur du frigo américain jeudi à
l'ats
il est ce qu'il attend une guerre non
vraiment j'ai jamais view des frigos
américain dans ma vie parce qu'on a on a
des poux petit alicebox glaciaire parce
qu'il ya manque d'électricité donc on
achète en petites quantités tous les
jours et donc j'étais vraiment je
pensais qu'ils avaient beaucoup plus de
choses que dans mon petit magasin
donc on adore ça on va au matin l'après
midi tranquille
ces gens on les connaît depuis des
années c'est le grand-père
après c'est le fils ses enfants et on
achète en vrac
ça fait des siècles on fait toujours ça
pas besoin bien sous d'emballage vous
venez vous discuté de tout et de rien
achètent même si vous voulez cinq grands
ils vous feront sans grand donc pas
besoin d'acheter en grande quantité et
avoir peur de voir de troisième guerre
mondiale par exemple
donc j'aime bien faire mon shopping on
entre avec des épices pendant on a aussi
chez moi des livreurs de lait parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'acheter de
grosses bouteilles de lait donc on a
chaque matin à 6h du matin en ahl ce
monsieur c'est ça ben othman en anglais
bien sûr il nous livre si vous avez
besoin
5 millilitres ou 2010 ministre vous
pouvez acheter le lait frais ce sont des
paysans qui vient au tour de new delhi
donc avant ils venaient en bicyclette au
rugby bien sûr la modernité c'est en
mode aux bicyclettes
donc ça sert bien seul chez moi en inde
alors pour la vaisselle ne dit pas formé
sous on a trop bu
on casse les selles mais on n'en doute
pas
même par exemple vous avez des disputes
entre maris femmes copains copines des
amants à monte on peut pas casser la
vaisselle
parce que toute la vaisselle sur l'inox
on les lave si ça tombe par terre on
s'en fout parce qu'on peut relever c'est
pas un problème
donc tous les magasins bien sûr on n'a
pas bien sûr des emballages en plastique
ni des vers celle qu'on jette tout le
temps quand je regarde quand je bois
plein de café ici chaque fois que je
jette j'ai peur vous savez le gobelet au
café donc j'adore ces magasins ils se
trouvent parfois que c'est ça fait
presque politique c'est l'art
contemporain on n'a pas besoin de musée
c'est dans la rue dans les magasins et
en plus on répare tout je vais partout
et chaque fois je repars au nahd
j'habite geste quatre mois trois mois en
inde
il omet de grandes valises des choses à
réparer
bien sûr je vais pas parapluie mais
parapluie que j'ai garçons france les
casseroles les poils donc on a des
tout-petits juin qu'il est partout et ça
fait des siècles parce qu'on peut pas
j'étais donc même j'appartiens à une
petite classe moyenne en inde
on ne peut pas gaspiller en fait en ce
sens même si vous avez des vêtements
vous pouvez me donner je peux les
réparer qui sont mangés par les mites
on a des spécialistes qui peut recoudre
tout et vous pouvez pas boire alors même
de ça rit ça reste très confortable
on était ce à votre corps les frais en
hiver et les shows et les six mètres il
n'y a pas de bouton
il n'y a pas deux éclairs fermeture et
en plus il est si m donc on peut être
gros vous devenu gros on peut devenir
une mince c'est la même taille taille
pour tout le monde et bien sûr ça c'est
bien de voir aussi qu'un aux vêtements
aussi sont assez durable et si tout
s'il y en tout vous pouvez cacher oui
bien sûr donc on a des réparateurs de
tous et bien sûr que tous ces choses qui
arrivent en ville
comment les camions pas possible avant
des camions parce qu'ils ont coincés
dans les embouteillages donc on a un
plan b
plombées depuis des siècles on a eu des
petites entreprises bien sûr ce sont des
gens qui ont leur entreprise ce sont des
auto entrepreneurs
ils travaillent honnêtement parce qu'on
a des millions et des millions de gens
et il livre non match à nice par exemple
toutes les marchandises arrivent à l'ada
vous appeler ces gens bien sûr des
portables votre smartphone
il arrive tout de suite il livre en
quelqu'un quelques heures même demi
heure donc toute la livraison arrive
bien sûr avec ses petites entreprises
qui sont vraiment indispensables pour
nous donc on a bien sûr vous voyez plan
b pas besoin d'application des choses
logistiquement sophistiqués c'est très
efficace même pour le déménagement c'est
efficace vieux vous assure donc parfois
je pense à ses couleurs des photos que
mes amis aussi ont pris en hâte c'est
mes photos et aussi des photos de mes
amis qui ont pris qu'ils étaient
impressionnés ils étaient presque
agréablement surprise qu'on a plein
d'idées en plus pour quoi faire
très compliqué si l'habit est tellement
simple vous avez un vélo vous fait un
petit chariot avec 4 e et vous
transportez vos bagages
donc voilà new delhi
new delhi aussi c'est moral bien sûr
on accepte et on est très contents tous
les jours même à new delhi la capitale
que la ruralité ventre dans notre espace
humain vous voyez la dame elle arrive
elle est tranquille avec sa vache parce
qu'elle peut pas rester dans son village
c'est exode rural bien sûr on doit les
accepter on n'a pas des pétitions contre
il doit aussi s'habituer à notre espace
et donc on est très contentes de voir
toutes les vaches au milieu de la route
les vaches sont sacrées donc on peut pas
les toucher on peut pas les tuer
il ya même des temples de rats parce
qu'on peut pas toucher des là il ya des
temples de singe il est ample de tous
les animaux donc bien sûr la ruralité
entre dans la capitale parce que moi je
suis très urbanisé branché mais ça m'a
fait plaisir de voir aussi bien sûr côté
humain la ruralité qui arrive dans
d'autres grandes villes
et imaginons que vous êtes à paris
champs elysées il y à vaches deux jours
à que vous promener comme ça mais pour
nous ça nous change pas ça fait partie
de notre paysage donc la ruralité c'est
important notre voyage est aussi avec
les singes
les sages ont appris leur habitat avec
toute la croissance bien sûr on est très
fertile
on a beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants
comment faire donc on a construit
beaucoup de maisons et allemands de la
ville
new delhi et on a pris leur espace et
aujourd'hui les singes ils m'ont dit
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
donc ils ont décidé de aussi à habiter
avec nous mais ils sont très
intelligents nos cousins ils ont ils ont
leur espace
mais dans le quartier très huppé
dassieu l'ambassade de france avait
plein dable des grands bâtiments
administrative où il ya plein d'arbres
des jolis endroits dans les quartiers
bien sûr très riche dans les bureaux des
anciens bureaux des ministres mais
pourquoi pas donc le singe aussi c'est
très sacré ils font partie de notre vie
quotidien on voyage avec eux en passe
notre temps mon université d construit
au milieu de la forêt donc on avait des
singes parfois avec des bébés dans la
salle de classe
oui donc ça c'était très intéressant
c'est mary universe qui donc vous pouvez
aller voir aussi notre l'université en
inde
donc le sage bien sûr toujours en
harmonie avec nous tous les animaux bien
sûr et bien sûr après avoir mangé tombe
de script foot il faut de l'eau on a des
livreurs d'eau donc nous perd une
facture officiel de l'eau
mes parents ils ont toujours en train de
se plaindre il ya une facture mais le
soir harry on achète le marché noir mais
c'est peu importe mes parents parfois
ils ont stressé si j'invite mes amis
français ils ont dit ah là là il m'a
tiré la chasse d'eau à dix litres ils
vont prendre une douche 30 litres
voulons des parts contre je pense ici
combien de litres vous allez si on
achète mille litres par jour dans la
marche et ses chiens c'est très cher
donc mais parfois mais mes parents sont
paniqués parce qu'on peut pas donner un
petit saut à des invités vous prendre
votre douche parce que les douces et
décoratif mais normalement on prend un
petit saut donc on arrive avec l'eau les
livres d'eau très efficace le service
est nickel très très bien vous pouvez
compter sur l'eau et après avoir mangé
but il faut aller aux toilettes bien sûr
qu'est ce que vous allez faire avec tout
ce que vous aimez manger on n'est pas
commun des mortels donc il faut aller
aux toilettes au la cible est donc je ne
sais pas si vous savez qu'il ya plus de
quatre milliards
des gens qui n'ont pas accès aux
latrines et on a aujourd'hui fêter la
journée mondiale des latrines
on a lieu bien sûr beaucoup de
financement de banque mondiale et
nations unies parce qu'il faut des
latrines et on a aussi un grand projet
hollande qu'on parle pas dans les
presses internationales
on va construire 600 millions de
latrines pour tout le monde donc dans
les années à venir 2084 journée sont dix
ans donc je sais pas si vous vous serez
encore vivant mais j'espère que on aura
des toilettes du pétrole en 2030 et
pourquoi pas des applications les
applications qu'ils nous embêtent
tellement nos mobiles nos smartphones
sont tellement saturé des applications
que vous pouvez plus utiliser donc à la
fin je pense juste un petit message que
s'ils restent à peu ringard c'est bien
si on est trop branché trop informatisé
quand ce sont peut-être inférieur par
rapport à des jeunes qui sont toujours
branché je trouve que le futur est dans
le passé donc je vous remercie